[Applause]  [Music]  I heard about you  didn't think you were real I'm real wise  useful  it's really exciting to bring Batman  back to the big screen  I'm putting together a team people with  special abilities stop right there I  mean I totally had a fan freakout moment  I cannot believe I'm standing next to  Batman Batman  for the first time understands that he  can't do this by yourself mom misses the  days when mom's biggest concerns were  exploding wind-up penguins a simple life  the new movie Justice League we see the  evolution of a new Batman he's moved on  from lone vigilante to recruiter and  leader we get to enjoy the adventures of  this group as they saved the world what  are your superpowers again a rich  I don't recognize this well I don't have  to recognize it we just have to save it  I need to bring us together  you  you